[Música]
a la buena miedosa esta entrevista
exclusiva de france 24 imágenes donde es
su primer día en la administración el
presidente joe biden cumplió su palabra
al regresar al acuerdo de parís y
prometió tomar amplias medidas para
frenar la crisis climática de hecho el
hombre encargado de liderar los
esfuerzos de eeuu estuvo aquí en parís
cuando se firmó el emblemático acuerdo
como secretario de estado de eeuu hoy es
la voz de más confianza del presidente
en lo que muchos consideran el asunto
más crítico de nuestra era john kerry
enviado especial presidencial de eeuu
para el clima también conocido como el
zar del queens muchas gracias por
acompañarnos gracias por recibirme es
posible afirmar que ha sido un año
turbulento para eeuu y para el cambio
climático en los años previos está usted
aquí en europa simplemente para volver a
recuperar la confianza de las demás
naciones obviamente necesitamos
compensar la inexcusable ausencia de
eeuu durante los últimos cuatro años
incluso aunque muchos de nuestros
alcaldes y gobernadores todavía
siguieran el acuerdo de parís pero sobra
decir que no creemos que simplemente
podamos regresar como si nada
volver a ganarnos el lugar debemos hacer
cosas pero estamos aquí porque debemos
trabajar juntos ahora es fundamental que
europa y reino unidos se unan y estén en
la misma página debemos armonizar
nuestros esfuerzos
nuestras economías representan dos de
las mayores economías del mundo a
grandes rasgos y creo que es fundamental
que sepamos cómo vamos a sacar el mayor
provecho de glasgow no estamos aquí para
señalar países estamos aquí para hacer
el trabajo según lo que nos digan los
científicos o no según ideologías ni
según políticas esto se trata de
escuchar la ciencia y de responder para
que las generaciones futuras sepan que
hicimos lo que teníamos que hacer para
hacer el trabajo
sin embargo recuperar la confianza
significa realizar acciones en su país
existe un riesgo de que el presidente
joe biden haya prometido demasiado
demasiado pronto no no creo que haya
prometido demasiado demasiado pronto
prometió que estaríamos involucrados
prometió que volveríamos al acuerdo de
parís lo hizo a las pocas horas de
ocupar el cargo
prometió tomar acciones para que el
gobierno se moviera en esa dirección
emitió órdenes ejecutivas para que esto
fuera un esfuerzo de todo el gobierno
prometió que construiría y mostraría
liderazgo apuntando a glasgow y class go
en su momento fundamental para todos
nosotros no sólo para eeuu para reino
unido o francia sino para el mundo
debemos unirnos para conseguir con las
promesas que hicimos en parís en este
momento no lo estamos nadie lo está y la
convención marco de las naciones unidas
sobre el cambio climático lo dejó claro
todos los países deben mejorar deben
aumentar sus ambiciones ese era el
propósito de los objetivos que se
establecieron para glasgow y ese es el
propósito para los próximos 10 años esa
debe ser la década de la decisión y la
década de la acción y todos los países
deben aumentar sus esfuerzos
todavía no sabemos cuál es la meta de
reducción de emisiones de eeuu lo
sabremos en las próximas semanas cerca a
la cumbre del 22 de abril por supuesto
muchos están especulando sobre lo que
sería un objetivo apropia hemos oído
muchas cifras apropiadas no 50% de
reducción es para 2030 idealmente cerca
a 60% podría afirmar que el objetivo
está dentro de ese rango no no puedo
decir nada simplemente porque la
decisión no se ha tomado y no lo sé
tenemos un equipo de personas que están
trabajando asiduamente con cada agencia
del gobierno de eeuu escuchando a las
personas tratando de saber cómo podemos
hacerlo mejor cómo podemos hacer más y
esa decisión se tomará en las próximas
semanas el presidente se comprometió a
anunciar la durante los justo antes de
la cumbre climática se suele escuchar
que el kobe 19 podría en realidad ayudar
a combatir el cambio climático pero cómo
se reactiva rápidamente una economía sin
depender de las medidas devoradoras de
energía o de los procesos que están
vigentes actualmente
bueno obviamente durante los primeros
días semanas y meses no se construirá
una nueva central pero se pueden tomar
decisiones y se pueden llevar a cabo
necesitamos reconstruir mejor eso es lo
que el presidente nos ha pedido a todos
que hagamos cada país estará destinando
número cada país estará tomando
decisiones sobre qué energía utilizar o
qué camino tomar
la clave es establecer la curva que
lleva a la reducción durante ese periodo
de tiempo en eeuu tenemos un inmenso
reto con nuestra infraestructura vimos
lo que pasó en texas ha sido una semana
necesitamos construir una red mucho más
efectiva e inteligente en nuestro país y
el presidente by dénia declaró que su
intención es introducir un gran proyecto
de ley de infraestructura
eso podría tener como consecuencia la
oportunidad para reconstruir mejor y
tener una mejor red eléctrica
desarrollar nuevos tipos de tecnología
volvernos mucho más efectivos y
eficientes y creo que el presidente se
está concentrando en hacer esto todos
los países pueden hacerlo si empiezan a
hacer ahora los planes ya establecer las
decisiones que ayudan a que eso ocurra
hay que aceptar que las emisiones han
aumentado a corto plazo no no hay que
hacerlo
eso puede cambiar muy rápido en cierto 7
por ejemplo hay muchas centrales de
carbón que operan en muchos lugares con
50 por ciento de eficiencia muchas están
perdiendo dinero y aunque existen
alternativas no están accediendo a la
red no pueden acceder al mercado se
pueden hacer diferentes cosas a nivel de
decisiones ejecutivas que podrían
rápidamente iniciar el proceso de
moverse con más rapidez
y creo que parte de eso es lo que el
presidente pide en espera que se discuta
durante la cumbre que presidirá el 22 de
abril las principales naciones emisoras
las principales economías del mundo
estarán invitadas a esta cumbre además
de países más pequeños más vulnerables y
afectados como manglares los estados de
las islas del pacífico y otros para que
todo el mundo comparta una visión sobre
cómo podemos manejar esta crisis perdida
sé que el presidente está profundamente
comprometido con ver que 20 de los
países más emisores que equivalen al 81
por ciento de todas las emisiones tomen
el liderazgo
deben dar un paso al frente y ser serios
con aumentar la ambición esa es la clave
de glasgow y es la clave de la cumbre
del presidente
usted está aquí en francia y se reunió
con el presidente de manuel más como
durante su visita en el panorama mundial
el presidente francés se presenta como
un campeón climático pero aquí enfrenta
muchas presiones por no cumplir con sus
promesas francia está haciendo lo
suficiente
francia está trabajando muy muy duro y
felicito y le agradezco al presidente
macro ha sido un líder ha aumentado los
esfuerzos ha hecho mucho mientras
donaldson sacó a eeuu de ese acuerdo y
ayudó a que europa mejorar también no
estaba solo en eso pero europa hizo un
magnífico trabajo estoy agradecido por
eso el presidente macro no constituyó la
comisión civil aquí
ellos han hecho un gran número de
propuestas por 149 pero sólo un pequeño
porcentaje sería aceptar antes del
parlamento
entiendo que el parlamento votara varias
de esas propuestas me reuní con el
ministro francés de finanzas y me reuní
con la ministra de ambiente para para
políticas
y creo que todos ellos están
comprometidos para que esto sea un no se
puede medir las personas antes de que se
realizan las cosas pero estamos muy
satisfechos con el esfuerzo que se está
haciendo y con el liderazgo que se está
demostrando y espero que francia adopte
muchas de esas medidas
no conozco todas las medidas no voy a
apoyar una u otra pero necesitamos
liderazgo y creo que europa está en un
lugar privilegiado ya estableció una
meta global europea muy fuerte 55 por
ciento de reducción eso es sólidos
y creo que europa será clave en ayudar
para ponernos al día en ayudarnos para
que glasgow sea un éxito
esto afirmó que no señalaría a ningún
país incluyendo a china el mayor emisor
del mundo pero este acercamiento amable
de no señalar ni acusar nos ha llevado a
un aumento de 37 grados en la
temperatura por lo menos es tiempo de
cambiar esa estrategia web esa no es la
estrategia que nos ha llevado a iu las
personas han sido muy explícitas sobre
algunos de los problemas que nos han
llevado a eso y yo he sido muy explícito
se lo diré ahora mismo es porque esos 20
países
ninguno de ellos incluyéndonos a
nosotros han reducido lo suficiente no
vamos a hacer señala mixtas si lo
hiciéramos no señalaríamos a nosotros
mismas entre otros
todos en este grupo de chile representa
el 30 por ciento de las emisiones del
mundo eeuu está de segundo con 15 la
unión europea está de tercera
india está de 4 si no se cuenta la unión
europea con una entidad individual india
a terceros y luego rusia y así todos
esos países realmente deben unirse para
reducir esas emisiones de manera común o
global responsable y multinacional
nosotros también aceptamos nuestra
responsabilidad para hacer nuestra parte
del trabajo y más de ser posible y eso
es lo que haremos el liderazgo del
presidente bailén ha sido muy claro él
hará todo lo posible para ayudar a eeuu
a compensar los últimos cuatro años y
para preparar el futuro estas segundas
semanas el jefe de las naciones unidas
antonio guterres desafió a los mayores
contaminantes a eliminar gradualmente el
carbón para 2030 eeuu podría hacer el
presidente fai dénia dijo que para 2035
habría una producción de energía libre
de carbón en estado francés
ahora que todo el mundo está tratando de
saber cuál debe ser el ritmo cómo
lograrlo cómo alcanzarlo
pero claramente el carbón se ha ido
eliminando en todo estados el presidente
camps se cerraron centrales eléctricas
de carbón a pesar de sus opiniones es
una tendencia que está viviendo lo que
estamos tratando de resolver ahora es el
que puede pasar como cuidar a las
personas involucradas en esta
transformación ayudarles ayudarle a esas
comunidades debe ser parte esencial del
proceso el presidente y el equipo están
evaluando todo eso en este momento
finalmente muchas personas incluyendo a
los estadounidenses y el fundador de
microsoft bill gates creen que
necesitamos una verdadera innovación
tecnológica para combatir esta crisis
climática está usted también deseando y
esperando un milagro energético
sería maravilloso que hubiera un milagro
energético por supuesto no contamos con
eso por eso estamos comiendo acciones
porque no podemos quedarnos sentados
esperando que suceda pero te ayudaría un
milagro a todos en el planeta claro si
pudiéramos tener una innovación en las
baterías y de repente tener 20 o 30 días
de batería o si hubiera un avance y lo
nuclear que hiciera que fuese imposible
que hubiera una fusión imposible que
hubiera un problema de desechos
imposible que hubiera problemas de
proliferación que fuera asequible
entonces tal vez tomaríamos este caso
fuera el hidrógeno es un milagro
potencial si podemos avanzar con la
suficiente rapidez y crear esa
transformación en resumen por mucho que
el presidente sea una persona de fe y
leyera la visualidad amable
su trabajo requiere que no se quede de
brazos cruzados esperando a que ocurra
es ayudar a crear es ayudar a crear algo
para enfrentar esta crisis
y lo haremos de una manera que no será
ni demócrata ni republicano ni liberal
ni conservador lo haremos con base en la
ciencia y en los pasos prácticos que
pueden servir para nosotros como país y
para el mundo debemos hacer un mejor
trabajo del que estamos haciendo
actualmente
podemos hacerlo por supuesto podemos
hacerlo a tiempo para lograr una
diferencia ese ese es el reto datos por
supuesto sentimos una profunda
responsabilidad para tratar de asegurar
y lograr
jonker y muchas gracias por acompañarnos
en france 24 gracias gracias a ustedes
por acompañarnos quédense con nosotros
para más información
[Música]